so what are you staying for what I want
to do is have you guys pick one word one
word that defines who you are you have
your one word biography this is what you
stand for this is the positive change
that you want to make in the world one
word and when you figure out what that
one word is that becomes a theme for
your entire social media campaign I'm
going to give you some examples Martin
Luther King stood for quality right and
the people who have a lot of success you
can you can sum them up in one word
because it's easy to spread their
message Nelson Mandela stood for freedom
Oprah Winfrey heart Steve Jobs
innovation you guys all know him this
guy is incredible he is a consummate
entertainer unbelief and for me this
isn't a marketing thing okay this isn't
coming up with a marketing slogan for
your company this is a personal
positioning statement this is your
personal branding everything I do is
about believe this isn't just what I'm
positioning myself as a company I
believe in entrepreneurs I can't help it
it's Who I am and so whatever company I
bring it to whatever social media
campaign I launch has to incorporate
belief and I sell a lot of programs and
seminars and worksheets and advertising
and sponsorships but if you read my
Twitter and Facebook and all the social
media channels it's never a pitch
because you have to get people to feel
something before they gonna take action
if they don't feel anything with your
business and what you're putting out
there you're not gonna get any results
you're gonna be sitting there saying why
aren't people sharing this stuff this is
gonna be right now the most important
exercise that you ever do with your
business we're gonna find your one word
today right now there is one word that
strings together your entire life okay
think about the books that you like to
read your friends the people who are in
your life where you enjoy their company
the movies you like to watch the songs
you listen to the companies you've
worked at or found that the jobs you've
had the quotes you like to read the art
you like to look at and consume there is
one word that strings them all together
you have to figure that out
for me it's belief I read books that are
about believe I like reading books about
people who have come from nothing and
become something they overcame huge odds
the friends that I have believed and
believed the movies that I watch are
about believe you know my favorite movie
I like the jobs movie you guys have seen
jobs it's a great movie you haven't go
check it out I like Seabiscuit
you guys know Seabiscuit maybe what the
horse why it has nothing do the
Entrepreneurship has nothing to do with
business whatever like this movie so
much because this is about the little
guy you know like the horse everybody
gave up on and he made it through all
that the struggles and in the the pain
he made it the companies I found that
the quotes are like the read are all
about belief so I challenge you today to
think about what that one word is in
your life and we're throwing up a new
hashtag hashtag MSM w the number one
word I want you to put it up right now